[موسيقى]
هو الصوت الآخر للأرجنتين
[موسيقى] التي
تنافس التانغو في الروح الوطنية
على بعد ساعة من العاصمة وأنا
بين الماشية الرعوية حيث
يُربى اللحم البقري الشهير في سهول بامباس الحشائش
[الموسيقى]
جيدًا اشتراه جدي
المزرعة في عام 1934 1934 ، نعم ، منذ ذلك الحين
، أصبحت في عائلتنا
، وأصر
والدي على الاحتفاظ بها نعم ،
وما
كان علينا الاحتفاظ
بها بالطبع حافظت إيفا بوليكي على الأومبو
كما يطلق عليها
اليوم أربعة أجيال هناك الآن
مصدران من  دخل أولئك الذين لديهم أربعة أرجل
وأكثر ربحية من أولئك الذين لديهم اثنين ،
فأنا أحب ماشيتي ولكن الشيء الأكثر أهمية
هو ما هي السياحة ،
لذا الماشية والضيوف نعم ، نعم ،
يأتي الضيوف المهمون الذين يدفعون الثمن مثلي إلى هنا ليروا طريقة مختلفة
لتربية أحدهم  هذا غارق في
التقاليد الأرجنتينية
التي شحذها الغاوتشو الإسبان
والأصليون الذين قاموا بترويض هذه
الأرض التي تبدو هنا الأرجنتين مثل
الأضلاع إذا كنت تقوم بحفل شواء هنا في
الأرجنتين ، فإن الأشخاص الذين يريدون هذا
أنا ساكن حقيقي في المدينة  أحيانًا يكون
شديد الحساسية بشأن حقيقة أن البقرة التي كنت
أجادلها بالأمس على الشواية
غدًا ،
لا أريد أن أبدأ نقاشًا عالميًا ،
لكن ها هو اللحم البقري وهو الأفضل
في العالم
نقانق فقيرة هنا لدينا بعض
نقانق الدم لدينا الدجاج  هنا إذا
ذهبت إلى أي منزل هنا في الأرجنتين
، فربما يكون لديهم شيء
صغير مثل هذا ولكن سيكون
لديهم هذا النظام لا بشكل عام عندما
يكون لدي أصدقاء ونريد أن نكون
معًا ، يتصلون بي ويقولون لك  أرغب في
الحصول على أسادو اليوم ، يعني
مجرد القدوم إلى منزلي أو شيء من
هذا القبيل ، ونحن نشارك اللحظة نعم هذا
نموذجي للغاية أريد شريحة لحم ،
أريد شريحة لحم عندما يكون لديك هذا
نعم وحتى الاختبار ،
هل أفضل لحم بقر في  العالم يأتي
من الأرجنتين التي
تتغذى على عشب تم
تربيته بشكل جميل
ومذبح بشكل مثالي ،
ولا أعرف ما إذا كان الأفضل يأتي من
الأرجنتين
ولكنه جيد الدم